let's talk about this freedom for a
moment this story here we got from the
daily beast
now uh the daily basis fake news as
newsguard says right here they say uh
you know
is fake news perceived question and they
claim
the biggest migrant caravan on collision
course with trump-era border order scott
bixby white house reporter now i can't i
can't prove this is real because
newsguard says dailybeast is fake but uh
can you guys tell me about what's going
on at the border is this the daily beast
actually for once publish a real story
so i mean what i killed what i could say
about the caravan i'm speaking with some
sources in mexico so the caravan right
now is between 10 000 to 15 000 people
now the reason why we always see
caravans and kind of rolling in in the
kind of these mass groups is because
they're technically not allowed to
travel legally through mexico so that's
why they roll they kind of go together
like that they get overpowered
authorities what the mexican officials
did and we've been trying to report on
it
is they actually granted these people
work visas so for the first time this
caravan is actually legally allowed to
travel through mexico meaning they could
hop on buses they could hop on taxis
because normally um when you're not
allowed to legally travel through mexico
as a migrant the mexican police actually
kick you off buses and train so this
group is actually legally allowed to
travel now because they are legally
allowed to travel we're not going to see
the 15 000 hit the border all at once
it's going to be more spread out they
are going to reach the board a little
bit quicker and according to our sources
they're going to be most of them are
going to be arriving through
south texas now one thing that i did
reporting on my last border trip we were
there for title 42 is if you guys
remember back in april texas governor
greg abbott made four agreements with
four different mexican state governors
along the border to beef up security
stop the flow of drugs and all that
stuff ever since then abbott has gone on
and touted that that agreement as a
success we've literally spent time in
mexico all over through those areas and
we we we just literally uh published the
investigation you guys have to check it
out but we we expose that the mexican
authorities don't even do anything i
mean we were literally jumping in the
water with the migrants crossing in with
them and everything we were embedded
with these groups and the mexican
authorities don't even listen to any of
abbott's orders the only day that the
mexican officials set up authorities on
the riverbanks and stop stop migration
is when governor greg abbott visited
eagle pass so then the mexican security
set it up in perez negros right across
and they put up a little show for greg
abbott but after that they don't even
listen to the united states president
amo didn't even attend the summit of
americas in los angeles president of
osavado buchelli uh president of
guatemala and honduras have been very
upset with with uh vice president kamala
harris and her handling of the border
crisis because naibu kelly the president
of says my goal is to keep the
salvadorans in el salvador but when you
guys do the open border policy well the
human smokes are going to take over so
you have four presidents that are very
key in this migration debate who didn't
even attend the summit america's i think
that's a huge loss foreign policy for
the bible yeah it's creating a loss of a
lot of brain drain and a lot of people
don't realize that this immigration
debate is far more complex than hey just
people want to come over here there's a
lot of other economic effects especially
when it comes to cheapening labor
especially when it comes to housing
costs going up especially with the
increase of immigration that are going
to have a net effect on the larger
economic picture that we're all dealing
with so it's far more complex and
there's far more things intertwined in
this that we don't even know that we're
that we're not even debating and talking
about and discussing
i wanted to ask you something you
mentioned that they've actually been
given the work visas to travel through
mexico this time why did that happen you
know the mexican officials because one
thing that they do is they don't like it
when a bunch of migrants are basically
in their towns so like basically the
first town that the migrants hit is
tapachula so they would do is they hit
tapachula and the mexican officials stop
them there and they said you're not
allowed to travel and basically what
happens is more migrants come and they
kind of kind of create a bottleneck i
don't know if you guys remember last
year when those 15 000 haitians all
arrived in del rio texas at once they
all started off in in tapachula but the
officials in top of chile got so
overwhelmed they just gave them work
like literally visas were like just just
leave and then all those haitians
traveled together and they ended up
crashing the border so that's one thing
that this president president of mexico
he feels no pressure from biden to do
absolutely anything and then the mexican
authorities are making a fool out of
greg abbott that's what we're trying to
try to expose in a report you know you
have we have a republican governor who's
touting his agreements as a success
where we're literally
jumping in the water with with migrants
like we're literally you know crossing
crossing with them and you know for a
lot of people uh watching this you might
think well look i live in ohio i live in
michigan i live in pennsylvania i'm not
a border town i don't care well you
might not be impacted by the migrants
you know coming in and drug smugglers
being car chases but that fentanyl still
is still coming into your state i mean
the number one state impacted by
fentanyl right now is ohio and it's
impacting the white working class you're
not gonna hear that in mainstream media
because any any issue that that impacts
white working class they they don't even
cover but but the phenomena issue has
become really a top concern that we've
been trying to cover even my own
hometown in palmdale i covered a
fentanyl death of a 22 year old guy
named jordan erickson he popped his knee
at a gym and a local came up to him and
gave him an oxycodone said hey jordan
take this
24 hours later jordan was dead because
it was a counterfeit pill and we're
seeing that phenomenon with 13 year olds
right now where they think they're
taking xc the first time they think
they're taking a vicodin ends up being a
counterfeit pill and the thing guys with
fentanyl there's no second chance you
know so it's uh it's we're in some scary
times
absolutely there's also a big haitian
community in tijuana because there's
been a lot of you know mass migration
that was happening in that town and in
that town you know the locals don't like
having to deal with this influx of of of
people i remember doing reporting on the
ground in tijuana and seeing this kind
of these kind of man-made camps that
they were building that were
have you seen those uh make tijuana
great again yes yes
yes yes there was there was rallies
there was rally specifically in tijuana
calling for better uh immigration laws
because we're seeing victims the victims
or the people who are told come across
everything's going to be great
corporations are taken advantage of a
lot of this cheap labor that they're
extorting and exploiting especially when
it comes to new people coming into this
country so you know this thing is far
more complicated than than we even
allowed and i just want to mention it
and then people are also being flown in
and bused in all over the united states
not just on the border towns i just want
to mention this this quick detail
because it's important for the audience
to know uh on the last trip that me and
drew actually did in yuma together we
were reporting we were running into
massive groups around three in the
morning crossing and right hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds and i think for
people who maybe don't understand
immigration you probably think oh well
they're coming from el salvador
guatemalan honduras we interviewed those
migrants they came from 11 different
countries me and drew ran across
russians afghanistan lots of men coming
from india i mean and it was single
males and and yeah georgia and then you
do an interview with them and like hey
are you guys you know worried that
you're gonna be deported under title 42
and they're like no not not in this
administration we're welcome and even
the border patrol their morale is low
because they don't even guard the border
anymore now immigrants i mean if you
guys ever go down to the border it's
fascinating immigrants cross the border
and look for the border patrol i mean
back in the day you know immigrants
cross the border and you want to invade
the border they look for the border
patrol because they they want to be
apprehended and they know they're going
to get released in the united states i
had one border patrol and told me said
jorge i don't even feel like a border
portraying i'm just an uber driver right
now they're literally uber and uber
service i mean
what's interesting too to go to luke's
point is
i talk to some of these mexicans down
there right because they'll be there on
the border on the other side
and uh the last time we were down there
in yuma i was talking to one of them and
i was like obviously this has gone up
right since biden he's like way up
you're local here he's like yes it's
gotten worse under biden and i was like
how do the mexicans feel about illegal
immigration like mexicans right
he's like we hate it we hate these
people coming in because it activates
the cartels
they're dirty
they're the pollution is insane the
garbage that's thrown everywhere all the
clothes and the trash he says they're
very entitled people they're very lazy
people they come to all the mexicans
locally and they trash their communities
just like the haitians that are
occupying in tijuana right they trash
their communities and they're just
entitled and they run around to the
mexicans saying give me money they
demand money they demand they're feeling
titled to everything so it's it's
interesting when you talk to some of the
mexicans and you're like
i think the media will paint them like
oh they just everyone wants to come into
the united states but some of the locals
there are like dude we hate these people
coming well the haitians have actually
assimilated into the tijuana community
and have their own neighborhoods there's
there's a whole
culinary kind of uh you know street and
and this was because they thought they
were going to go to the united states
there were strict border patrols um that
that were you know used uh they were
stuck in tijuana and they created a
community there and and uh they're
working cohesively there but you know
you do talk to a lot of mexicans
mexicans who are proud of their country
who love their country and they're
troubled because this brings crime this
brings violence and and human extortion
which is absolutely horrible no one wins
out of this except for the multinational
corporations and the politicians who are
using this as a way to get more power
out of it and this is all on the backs
of so much suffering so many people are
getting screwed over and and that's the
aspect here that people really need to
understand the human cost to all of this
i don't know if you remember luke back
in i think it was like oh six bernie
bernie sanders was doing an interview
and the journalist asked him you know
why don't you support uh open borders
and even bernie says like wait a minute
why would i support open borders that
that's what the corporations want that's
like brothers yeah yeah yeah
and right the journalists were like oh
my god this progressive and i mean even
bernie knows even bernie knows but i
mean now he won't say it because of how
kind of crazy the the left has got there
but even bernie knew bernie the koch
brothers are doing this to us but this
is we see this all the time we see this
all the time with the left in the united
states and we've talked about it when it
comes to women's liberation for example
they'll say we are just bleeding heart
people who have everyone's best
interests in mind and that's why we want
to make changes to the social order it's
like okay well then women enter the
workforce in mass and wages stagnate
because you've doubled the workforce and
then they go well we just want to bring
more people into our country because
they're all asylum seekers and we want
to improve their lives oh my goodness
also it happens to be the case that the
neoliberal elite is going to make an
insane profit off of all of these people
coming to the country who are used to
third world wages and those are going to
be the folks competing with your average
american for labor and for jobs you give
them citizens
i know i'm such a i'm an unbelievably
horrid person
bernie sanders is just funny to me
because uh he's you know he's out of
vermont right pretty sure yeah yeah
and in vermont they have some like
really great gun laws he was and he was
against gun control and now he's like i
think this bipartisan bill doesn't go
far enough
more gun control and i'm like bernie
what happened is it lockheed martin um
have a major factory in vermont i think
it's lockheed uh i have to double check
that he goes no one needs guns except
the cartels to bring those asylum
seekers those are the only people who
need cops and if you're gonna cross
illegally just wear your mask and stay
six feet away from the border patrol
bernie sanders know what they done split
me because i have four houses or does
they have three houses he has three this
is what i find hilarious right when you
bring up the fact that bernie sanders
has three houses they go well that's not
hypocrisy he's just a socialist who has
houses he doesn't live in it's like okay
if i had three houses and i rented two
of them out you'd be calling me a
landlord and a parasite he has three
houses
just keeps two of them empty most of the
time and he's a philanthropist yeah what
about all the migrants what about all
the homeless all the homeless pirates i
just think the migrants
i just think it's hilarious
that owning a house and making use of
your capital by renting it out to other
people so someone who can't get a
mortgage is able to live there is evil
and makes you a parasite but having
extra houses and just keeping them empty
in case you want to go there on a whim
is perfectly moral and ethical and how
dare you even question the fact that
that's how bernie sanders lives while
calling himself a socialist we need to
get according to his wants that's right
if you write
if you write a best-selling book of
course yeah
well mark said that to each according to
their needs what from each according
from their to each according to the
needs for me to point their ability and
to
their need and don't forget if you write
a really good book you can have a bunch
of extra stuff there's a bunch of extra
stuff well one question i would really
like to ask bernie sanders is
i know that like if you write a
best-selling book you're just entitled
to all the profits from it but i'm
curious like what about the people who
had to uh cut down the trees and and
obtain the lumber that was then
converted into the paper for that book
like shouldn't they get it you know a
proportional share of the profits that
it made why is it just the guy who puts
the ink on the page that makes all the
money thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there